I'm talking about like hook up  situations like they actively if they're  having sex with her and like you you  like comed in her and you actively did  that and she has to go the next morning  get the morning after pill or if she's  too late for that she has to get the  abortion maybe you don't know him like  what repercussions does he okay but she  she gets that she gets that choice man  if they if they're both doing the same  thing right they're both irresponsible  in the situation so the woman gets to  have the freedom to get the plan b or  the abortion he has no choice like if he  got her pregnant he doesn't believe in  abortion what choice does he have none  if she wants to put him on child support  what choice does he have no